hours before the assault on Normandy's
beaches a nighttime drop of forces took
place behind enemy lines 250 were due to
have parachuted over this field today
once the western flank of the offensive
high winds in the end disappointed the
thousands who'd come to remember it
didn't seem to matter what they went
through in order to give us our freedom
that we can come here and talk about it
today we were here in 2004 for the 60th
and this for the 70th is even bigger
even though there are very few surviving
veterans that are able to attend here
before 5000 landing an escort craft
could move in towards shore the 50 miles
of coastline was targeted by an
extensive aerial and naval bombardment
only then could attempts be made to
control the beaches the extent of the
chaos that ensued can be seen in these
newly released photographs taken from
RAF reconnaissance planes 1,000 feet
above the beaches they show ships laden
with troops approaching shore and larger
naval vessels hanging back offering
vital support and also incredible and
moving scenes on the beaches themselves
it's hard to imagine what must have been
going through the minds of the nearly
hundred and sixty thousand Allied troops
who crossed the English Channel on d-day
in what was the largest seaborne
invasion in history and for the British
it meant many of them arriving here at
sword Beach the third British Infantry
Division was met with a beach that was
heavily mined littered with obstacles
and hence difficult to clear the soon
congested sands meant around 1,000 lost
their lives here it's why it's not just
world leaders who will come here to
remember the 425,000 allied and German
forces who lost their lives in the
battle for Normandy but those simply
grateful for peace and also those who
helped bring it about
lest we forget we'll all come down to
whether future generations will remember
those who trod these sands in much
darker times Paul Harrison Sky News in
Normandy